welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and what is modoc's plan in Ant-Man and
the WASP quantumania I mean with the
return of Darren cross to the MCU so
many people want to know how this crazy
computerized Cranium is going to cause
chaos with King the Conqueror well if we
look at Darren cross's history I think
we can get a good idea of what he could
be up to and I have a feeling that he
could be behind all of Scotland's
miseries and potential death in this
final film of this Ant-Man Trilogy so
let's look at all those Clues together
my nerd babies all right so what could
Modoc be planning in Ant-Man in the lost
quantumania well to put it bluntly Modoc
is the mental organism designed only for
killing in the Marvel Comics so that is
exactly what modoc's function is going
to be in Ant-Man 3. a freaking killing
machine and while modak in the comics is
a different person by the name of George
Tarleton comic modoc's murderous
mentality is exactly in line with Darren
cross's character from Ant-Man 1. before
Scott Lang deformed his body and led him
to become this big-headed monstrosity we
know from the first Ant-Man film that
Darren Cross isn't the most mentally
stable man I mean the last time we saw
him he was literally on a massive
revenge tour Vendetta against Scott Lang
and Hank pin's family after they ruined
his plans to sell the Yellow Jacket
armor to sketchy terrorist organizations
like the ten rings and hydro and even
went S4 as to kidnap Scotland's little
tiny daughter Cassie in order to attempt
to murder him in front of that little
daughter Cassie in his deranged quest
for Retribution much like he wanted to
execute hang Pym in front of his
daughter Hope just a few minutes before
that because they dared to cross the
cross but there is a reason for Darren
cross's mental instability and hope
brings us up as she tries to appeal to
Darren cross's Humanity when he has them
all at gunpoint in the first film this
is not who you are
altering your brain chemistry because
you see when Darren cross took over Hank
pym's business after he forced Hank out
Darren cross discovered a substitute
particle to the pen particle that
allowed him to successfully shrink down
living organic matter while also
increasing the user's strength with that
latter part being something that Hank
pym's pimp articles could not do as the
user only retained their normal strength
while being shrunk down when I took over
this company for Dr Pim I immediately
started researching a particle that
could change the distance between atoms
while increasing density and strength so
increasing your strength is like
something that is new to the new formula
however repeated exposure to the
radiation from that new particle altered
Darren cross's brain and increased his
already super vindictive nature times
like a thousand to the point we're
killing people that got in his way
became super comfortable and necessary
to him much like when he killed poor old
frank when Frank dared to question the
safety of his yellow jacket suits after
cross's very concerning presentation
about the military applications of the
literally just shrunk them down into
tiny Frank paste and then flushed them
down the turret and when I say that that
presentation was concerning it really
was because Darren cross was about to
unleash the ultimate stealth Army that
the world has never seen before the
single Yellow Jacket offers the user
unlimited influence to carry out
protective actions and one day soon an
army of yellow jackets will create the
sustainable environment of well-being
around the world and I think this is all
going to come into play in Quantum
medium with Modoc because as we've seen
in the quantumania trailers Cassie Lang
has been able to make a device that is
capable of communicating with the
quantum realm and we can even see a
keyboard connected to the console that
she uses to do so implying that Cassie
has been chatting with someone from that
very realm and I feel like that person
is none other than the eventful Darren
cross using Cassie Lang much like he
used her in the first film as a man with
even more murder on his mind now that
his maniacal melon has been magnified by
Misfortune make no mistake everybody
Darren cross is still very cross with
the Langs pims and bandines for ruining
all of his life's work and making him
into a deformed man with a forehead that
makes Jimmy Neutron look like a Pez
dispenser
and hey guys the beginning of the year
is a great time to sort out all the
stuff that you didn't sort out last year
you know like your life your health the
amount of money that you put aside for
movie merch impulse buys
some of that stuff is hard to do but
some of it is super easy like you could
seriously up your skincare in hygiene
game by checking out geology geology is
a 16-time award-winning personalized
skin care company recognized in high
Beast birdie Men's Health Esquire and
ask men grooming Awards with over 6 000
5 Star reviews and they've recently
expanded to offer products for pretty
much whatever you need all you gotta do
is take a quick 30 second diagnostic
quiz and geology figures out your
routine for you geology creates simple
and effective skin care and Hair Care
routines customized just for you with
ingredients that are proven to work no
matter what you're trying to take care
of for hair care you can use geology's
co-wash especially formulated cream
cleanser that removes buildup and
cleanses the hair without the big lather
or harsh ingredients of typical shampoo
geology also has body washes that are
free of harsh ingredients smell great
and are refillable for skin care geology
helps you protect your skin from
environmental stressors with vitamin C
and vitamin E for serum to keep your
skin looking young and healthy and then
a bit of dermatologist tested aluminum
free deodorants to keep your armpits
smelling not stinky right now for a
limited time geology is hooking up our
viewers with an absolutely insane offer
listen up if you use code rockstar70
they will give you an additional seventy
seven zero percent off their
award-winning skin care trial set we do
the math and that's five products for
just fifteen dollars and on top of that
you can take an additional 30 bonus
offer on one of their brand new skin
hair and body products of your choice
when you add it to your trial to get
started with geology just click the link
in the description we thank geology so
much for sponsoring this video you guys
are amazing and there's also the chance
here that modoc's exposure to all of the
yellow energy of the quantum realm could
be affecting modoc's mind even more much
like his exposure to the yellow energy
radiation from his suit and made him
into a murdering Menace I believe that
Modoc lured the pims Langs and Van dynes
to the quantum realm just so he can have
his revenge on all the people who
wronged him while also hitchhiking a
ride out of his Quantum realm prison
with his new multiversal buddy King the
Conqueror possibly also even equipping
King's army with the yellowjacket
technology that he was going to sell to
the Tang rings in Hydra to help him
invade the Multiverse and in the most
stealthiest way possible that you cannot
stop a Kang Army that can shrink and
grow at will the Multiverse will fold in
a second like if you saw Hank Pym in the
yellowjacket armor kill all the Avengers
in what if you know just how crazy
having just one yellow jacket suit in
the wrong hands can be like a whole Army
of Yellowjackets would decimate the
entire timeline while also giving Modoc
the unique opportunity to kill the Langs
pims and Van dynes in every Universe
like the killing machine that he is and
I have a feeling that he's going to go
after Scott Lang in every universe but
yeah in short Mod's plan is to be a
mental organism designed for killing to
kill but since his exposure to Quantum
radiation has affected his mind to such
a drastic degree his bloodlust might
just lead him to try to cause a genocide
of multiversal proportions just to prove
that he is the biggest brain in 616.
that is what I believe modok's plan is
for the MCU in this film what do you
guys think let us know in the comment
section below thank you guys so much for
watching this video you follow me at
mess retainment on Twitter if you guys
want to see me tweet some weird ships
and really fun theories especially the
hashtag the Marvel trigger Theory which
I always tweet about on my Twitter it's
about all the infinity energies and it's
really really interesting so follow that
on Twitter if you want to but more
importantly you can follow your
rockstars wherever we are on the social
media make sure you hit that Bell down
below if you want to get all the
notifications whenever we upload a video
I love you guys so much and I feel like
I don't tell you guys that as often as I
should but I love you guys 10 million
bajillion and I'll see you guys next
time bye
[Music]
[Applause]